يقول إن والده ولد في ألمانيا
دعابة
أنه لم يستمع إلى هذا والدي هو
ألماني ، وكان ألمانيًا ومولودًا
في مكان رائع جدًا في ألمانيا ، لذلك
لدي شعور كبير تجاه ألمانيا ،
والدي من ألمانيا ، وكلا
والديّ  من الاتحاد الأوروبي أخبرك أن
والديّ وُلدا في قطاعات الاتحاد الأوروبي ، حسنًا ، أعني أن
والدتي كانت اسكتلندا ، والدي كان من
ألمانيا ، وُلد أبي في برونكس ، نعم
، القسم الرائع في ألمانيا الذي
يُدعى برونكس نيويورك
فيل ، كيف ترى ذلك جيدًا أنا أنظر  في
هذا وألقي نظرة على ما كنا عليه
في السنوات القليلة الماضية ، وأعتقد
أن الرئيس قد أدرك ما إذا
كان يتحدث عن شهادة ميلاد أوباما
أو ما إذا كان يتحدث
عن حجم الحشود في حفل التنصيب
أو ما إذا كان يتحدث عن
والده.  تراثه أدرك عندما
يخرج إلى مسيرة أن الناس لا
يهتمون ، إنه أمر لا يصدق ، أعني أنه يستطيع أن
يقول شيئًا سيعرفه الجميع في
غضون 30 ثانية من خلال النظر إلى
ويكيبيديا أن والده لم يكن  rn في
ألمانيا ولا يزال يدرك أن 40٪
من السكان يقولون مرحبًا ، إذا كان بإمكانك
تقديم أداء أفضل للجيش الجمهوري الإيرلندي الخاص بي ،
فأنا لا أهتم بما إذا كان والدك قد
ولد في برونكس التي أعتقد أنها في
مكان ما بالقرب من ميونيخ أو ما إذا
كان والدك  ولد في نيويورك
أدرك أن الناس لا يهتمون بهذه
القطعة الرائعة